hello everyone and welcome back to the
show that begs the question
you ever dance with the devil in the
pale moonlight
today it's joker's wild as we prepare
for joaquin phoenix to give us his spin
on the classic super villain
so which of his predecessors is the best
joker of all time
let's take a walk down memory lane and
meet our contestants
the following list are handsome actors
that have appeared as joker in at least
one theatrically released movie caesar
romero
mark hamill jack nicholson keith ledger
jared leto and zach galifianakis okay
are you making some of those up nope
they're all real
probably worth the google so many
eligible bachelors only one rose
jared leto don't hold your breath
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office slash tomato meter
round two most memorable round three the
most dastardly planned
and then we'll do a wild card round
that's our plan and it is indeed
horrifying
let the feast of fools begin listen
boopsie
introduce a little anarchy you can call
me
joker round one box office slash tomato
meter
much like a nutty joker experiment we've
combined the box office and tomato meter
into one
giant category green plus tomatoes so
we're calling this round
salsa verde jokers tend to do well at
the box office because he usually comes
with a
side of batman but i'm gonna give the
biggest shout out to jared leto's
version here
because in suicide squad batman barely
showed up
you get one quick scene of him battling
joker then bruce wayne mails in a cameo
picks up his check and leaves
and suicide squad is actually the third
highest grossing film featuring a joker
ever
raking in over 784 million dollars
worldwide
so does that mean jared leto could
actually win this round
no you don't want no beef you don't want
no beef suicide squad stands at a rotten
27 percent of the tomato meter and it's
looking up at every other joker-centric
film
according to said tomato meter the dark
knight stands on top of the tallest
gotham building at 94 percent
followed by the lego batman movie mask
of the phantasm at 84 percent
batman the movie kaplao at 78 1989's
batman at 71
the killing joke at 40 and then finally
last the oscar-winning suicide squad
still getting a trophy
even though it's in last place are you
sweet talking me
fun joker fact the dark knight is the
highest rated of the christopher nolan
batman films they average 88 percent
and 1989's batman is second highest
rated of the tim burton
joel schumacher movies they only average
49.5 percent
hey mr freeze thanks for putting that
franchise on ice
that's my exit queue so given the dark
knight's impressive tomato meter and the
fact that it grows 1.25
billion dollars worldwide what could
possibly compete against that robust mix
of acclaim
and dollar dollar bills well not the
mark hamill joker flicks
mask of the phantasm is epic and i
bought it on vhs the day it came out
but it only did 12 million dollars
worldwide at the box office and the
killing joke only did 4 million
but don't count out all that animated
fare just yet the lego batman
movie made 312 million dollars
internationally
and was universally praised by both
critics and my nephew
blink blink blink blinky blink blink
bling unfortunately we don't have
reliable box office data for the 1966
batman the movie because people are too
busy freaking out over dillon plugging
in
so the only real contender to heath
ledger in this category as far as
reception
and money is jax joker in the summer of
1989
you could not escape batmania theaters
were packed
tickets were sold out merch was flying
off the shelves turn on the radio
it's another bat-tuned by prince
the film would go on to make 975 million
dollars worldwide and yes
i adjusted for inflation and the 1989
batman film
that's the movie that introduced me to
movie theater nachos
have not seen my abs since they're on
the side of a milk carton
how are your abs bro too much flab not
enough ab
but if we're looking at both green and
tomatoes we'll fry him up call jessica
tandy
and say heath ledger's joker is the
highest on the tomato meter
and the biggest of the box office this
is an easy call
round number one goes to heath
it's gone
round two most memorable if you gotta go
go with a smile this round will reward
that joker that most stands out from the
pack heath ledger certainly fits that
bill
and the academy agreed his joker put all
comic book films on its back
as he ushered them into a new age of
acceptance with both general audiences
and ward voters the only slightly
tethered madness that he shows
in scenes like the mob boss meetup and
the hospital explosion
steer that face into our memories one of
the ultimate reminders of alfred's
cautionary words
some men just want to watch the world
burn
and we know batman remembers him why
because he offed his girlfriend
it's not funny i don't know why i'm
laughing and i thought my jokes were bad
not quite as remarkable was jared leto
not because his performance wasn't good
i liked his take and the backstory that
this is a former gangster
gone insanely rogue has merit he looks
good shooting a tommy gun
and i wish him and harley all the best
if that's what she wants but at a paltry
seven minutes on screen
lettuce simply didn't have the time to
give him a shot in this round
enter mark hamill in an inspired twist
on the character
hamill infused the joker with an
insatiable need to not only torment
batman
but to have batman around because
without a hero being a villain just
ain't as much fun those impeccable
sadistic laughs reverberate throughout
the batcave
[Laughter]
and the panache of this joker cannot be
oversold how memorable was mark hamill's
take
he sang jingle bells batman smells robin
laid an egg
the batmobile lost the wheel of the
joker
[Music]
that's the best christmas carol since
grandma got crushed by that reindeer
look both ways next time myrtle zach
galifianakis brought a ton of fun to his
role and offered a genuinely different
outlook
like hamill his joker knew life was
better with batman in it
and he took it a step further go watch
that movie again he
kind of just wants to be friends with
batman i'm off the menu
you won't get to fight any of this
anymore he's got villain dna for sure
but more than anything he's an outcast
that longs to be the member of a
community i hate you more
i hate you the most i hate you forever
no one should receive more credit for
this commune of jokers than the
legendary
caesar romero the over-the-top clownish
nature of his reactions became one of
the signatures of the batman series
and the accompanying 1966 film you never
knew what that joker was going to do
but you knew it'd be worth watching
[Laughter]
then we get to jack look i asked the
beginning of the round
who is the most memorable jack had the
one-liners the wonderful toys the
general insanity that we cannot get
enough of
that purple suit his flair for blasting
music and defacing priceless art the
entrances
the exits the gags that were so non-stop
they kept him laughing after he died
haven't you ever heard of the healing
power of laughter
we see glimpses of this side of jack
napier's personality and then after
tumbling into evada chemicals
and seeing one of gotham's finest
plastic surgeons it's the perfect blend
of mayhem
to combat the batman jack nicholson wins
and he's tied heath ledger at one round
a piece
as my plastic surgeon always said if you
gotta go
go with a smile round number three
the most dastardly plan the joker loves
being a thorn in batman's side and he
always seems to come up with a plan to
foil the caped crusader that is equal
parts genius
ridiculous and usually very expensive
you ought to know you bought it
luckily in the world of animation it all
costs about the same
whereas zach's joker went to the phantom
zone mark hamill's had a blast in the
animated series
literally he not only blew up popular
gotham events he wanted to gas the
entire city
and in his most creative pursuit he
wanted to turn all the city's fish
into joker fish i got to be honest
that's not going to affect me all that
much
and when i think about it red lobster
could put them in their kids meal that
could actually stimulate the local
economy in gotham
anyway hamill took it nine steps further
in 2016's a killing joke when he shot
and paralyzed batgirl
yeah that happened hello r rating
heath ledger's joker wanted general
social unrest and anarchy but he went
about it with some insanely intricate
plots and a lot of very obedient
henchmen
from the bank robbery that kicks off the
dark knight to the rope-a-dope of batman
and getting him to rescue the wrong
person
where's rachel nicholson wanted to gas
the city at a parade but he also
poisoned axis chemicals to kill
people while leaving a crazed grin on
their face love
that joker money money money
then jared leto wanted more harley quinn
facetime
boo hoo they're all competing for second
place in this category have you heard
what caesar romero's joker was all about
every time the dude showed up he had
some harebrained scheme
he kidnapped the maharishi he tried to
gas everyone at a boat launching he
started art classes as a front for
extortion he turned the city's water
supply
into gelatin there's always room for
jello
oh and he built a flying saucer and he
started taking surfing lessons
we're not sure if the surfing lessons
was to combat batman or for exercise but
either way bring your shark spray caesar
wins this round
going away he who lasts last
lasts good
and now we've arrived at the wild card
round the most
iconic caesar romero certainly gets
points in this round because
he gave life to a character only known
from the comic book page
and he provided a trickster template for
any joker that followed
leto and galifianakis have only really
been in one go-around thus far
i think it's fair to say those haven't
been as memorable as the one timers
wrought by jack nicholson or heath
ledger
jack came upon this role at the perfect
point in his career
he was a huge star and he could inject
his own playboy personality into the
character
his jack napier made a perfect foil for
keaton's bruce wayne
and we can never thank him enough for
all the one-liners he donated to the pop
culture lexicon
never rub another man's rhubarb then
heath ledger made us forget all that for
over two hours
he won a posthumous oscar gave a darker
more damaged edge to the character
and teased the audience with any number
of backstory riddles that
we'll never solve but it was only in one
movie
although he does win the screen time
award for live-action jokers in a single
film
heath's turn had 33 minutes of screen
time in the dark night
edging out nicholson in 1989's batman by
30 seconds
mark hamill gave birth to his version of
the twisted trickster a decade and a
half before heath ledger
and took us further into the pathos of
the legendary villain than we'd ever
been before or since
reinventing his own career in the
process mark hamill set out to
illuminate us with the unhinged sickness
of either a mob assassin or a failed
comedian i'm crazy enough to take on
batman
but the irs no thank you in a cool
interview with rotten tomatoes he said
he wanted to differentiate the joker's
laugh like
the colors on a palette where it
reflects his mood
accentuating that mood is the look the
pointed nose the wide grin the yellowish
eyes and teeth
that's all good stuff so good in fact
that it wins in this round
hello gotham joker's back in town
and now it's time to make my decision as
to who is the greatest joker of them all
currently we have a four-way tie between
romero nicholson
hamill and ledger so between them i'd
have to say
my favorite is fun sidebar time
so our expert researcher here at rotten
tomatoes is mark hoffmeyer
he's known locally as the mark that
actually works on this show i didn't
write that he compiled a list that was
called from 10
different publications such as esquire
variety etc
who all had done their own individual
joker rankings here's how mark's
compilation shook out
heath ledger was the overall number one
followed in order by mark hamill
jack nicholson cesar romero zach
galfinakis
and last jared leto so using all of that
and factoring it into the tiny univac
inside my head
heath ledger's joker was really
brilliant a performance not just for all
time
but for all times let's put a smile on
that face
however when i think of the character of
the joker a villain born in the comics
back in
1940 the most accurate representation of
everything that that super villain has
come to be and represent is
mark hamill's joker yes mark hamill gets
the win
i mean what happened
[Music]
these diseased lunatics are right yes we
are
i am not going to be part of a one-sided
relationship
any longer the cackle the style the
emotional relationship betwixt him and
batman sealed the deal
and i'm so happy that i did not let down
my personal dear friend
mark hamill here's a pic of us about to
enjoy a quiet meal at applebee's
mr chase on the rebound baby congrats to
all our competitors and lest mark hamill
get a big head
just remember the greatest hero in the
star wars galaxy
r2d2 hands down no contest he saved
everybody multiple times
[Applause]
last but not least is the part of the
show where you the people
have the burden of voting for your
favorite joker all you have to do is
comment below with your take and have
fun defend your answer get involved
we love hearing from you all because in
the words of an insane psychopath
no no no no
you complete me
was i doing heath ledger tom cruise you
can debate it we'll see you real soon
i'm mark ellis but you can call me
[Music]
joker
[Applause]
you